restaurant has been struggling because
of a slowdown
in business the malaysian government has
imposed a third
nationwide lockdown for a month starting
on wednesday
while businesses and other economic
activities are allowed to operate
restaurants can only offer takeaways
approximately 40 percent of all the
clusters in malaysia over the last
three months have come from
manufacturing in factories
and the restaurant industry and dining
inn is only contributed
approximately 0.31 when we have this one
month lockdown
what guarantee is there that it's not
going to come back again because you are
closing the wrong people
malaysia is still battling its third
wave of the pandemic
which started last september the
lockdown includes restrictions on travel
and school closures taiwan says it will
tighten prevention measures in all
business venues after reporting
16 new domestic profit 19 cases on
wednesday
the health minister warns the alert
level may be raised in the coming days
which would include the closure of
non-essential businesses
taiwan has managed to keep infections
low by closing its borders
early in the pandemic and by conducting
extensive tracing and imposing strict
quarantine measures
thailand and the philippines have
reported their first cases this week
of a virus variant first detected in
india
the world health organization has
classified the strain as a variant of
concern
indicating it's become a global health
threat
experts say vaccination programs are
crucial to containing the spread
once you have a population vaccinated
widely
uh studies have shown even the rating of
concern
may not be a big of an issue you can
still curtail it
pretty well but the problem is
vaccinating enough of the population to
reach herd immunity quickly
statistics show that asian countries
have vaccinated approximately only 4.6
percent of their populations
on average florence louis al jazeera
kuala lumpur